This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个I-Heart播客。保证真人。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，关于心理韧性、健身和建立复原力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
让自己经历一些磨难，你就会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《2%》。在《Look Back at it》播客中。从1979年开始，那对我来说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我来说也很重要。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会挑选一年，拆解当时发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何度过那一年的。与我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员和最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.
在IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行一些在其他任何地方都不太安全的坦诚对话，但你是在与一位知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人穿着盔甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
在AHA电台应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控让人生下双胞胎。但怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吧？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一支互联网侦探大军来揭露一个令人不安的模式。还有两个男人也经历过同样的事情。格雷格，一个女同性恋者。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands.
迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的大脑被震撼了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着这一季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。在Iheart电台应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。当一群女性发现她们都与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定采取行动。
I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. I'm Gemma Spike and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk
我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他不会逃脱惩罚的。他会得到他应得的。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。收听《The Girlfriends》。相信我，宝贝。在Iheart电台应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听。大家好。我是杰玛·斯派克，欢迎回到《20多岁的心理学》，这是一个我们讨论的播客
through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. It is so great to have you here back for another episode. I am very excited for this episode because I think it's something that a lot of us are going to find relevant and very revealing. Today, we are talking about serial monogamy or relationship hopping. I think it is safe to say we have all had, we all know that one person, that one friend who seemingly cannot stay single for any period of time, who's always in a relationship. We all have encountered that person in our dating lives who maybe wants something suspiciously fast despite having just gone through a breakup,
我们20多岁时最大的变化、时刻和转变，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。很高兴你能回来收听新的一集。我对这一集感到非常兴奋，因为我认为这对我们很多人来说都是相关且非常有启发性的。今天，我们讨论的是连续一夫一妻制或频繁更换伴侣。我认为可以肯定地说，我们都认识那样一个人，那个似乎在任何时候都无法保持单身的朋友，总是处于一段关系中。我们在约会生活中都遇到过那样的人，尽管刚经历过分手，却可能想以令人怀疑的速度开始下一段关系，
somebody who really seems to be hell bent on finding a relationship after only just ending one very, very previously, very shortly before. Maybe you are that person. This is what we're talking about today, relationship popping. This situation, phenomena, where somebody jumps quickly from relationship to relationship without really leaving any time for emotional processing, for healing, for self-reflection. It's not simply going on a few dates after a bad break. breakup or meeting a new person kind of serendipitously after a bad breakup. We've all done it.
一个在刚刚结束一段关系后，似乎就一心想要寻找下一段关系的人。也许你就是那个人。这就是我们今天要讨论的，频繁更换伴侣。这种情况，这种现象，即某人迅速地从一段关系跳到另一段关系，而没有真正留出任何时间进行情感处理、治愈或自我反思。这不仅仅是在糟糕的分手后约会几次，或者在糟糕的分手后偶然遇到一个新人。我们都做过。
We've all, I think, had those moments where, well, maybe not all of us, but I think it's pretty normal to sometimes have those moments where a relationship ends and you happen to find somebody really amazing pretty soon after. What we are talking about instead is this pattern of quickly needing emotionally significant relationships to follow each other. very much needing exclusivity, needing a partner in your life, often having very little space in between the people you date. Before we let our minds assume that this is a personality floor, I have got to remind you, this isn't necessarily bad. Like I said, some people genuinely thrive in partnership, they date intentionally, perhaps for religious or personal reasons,
我想我们都有过这样的时刻，好吧，也许不是我们所有人，但我认为有时会有这样的时刻，一段关系结束了，你碰巧很快就找到了一个非常棒的人，这很正常。我们讨论的相反是这种需要情感上重要的关系接连不断的模式。非常需要排他性，生活中需要一个伴侣，通常在约会对象之间几乎没有空隙。在我们让大脑认为这是一种性格缺陷之前，我必须提醒你，这并不一定不好。就像我说的，有些人确实在伴侣关系中茁壮成长，他们有目的地约会，也许是出于宗教或个人原因，
and that's fine. But the question is, What do you lose when you do that, if anything? And why do some people feel almost unable to be single, whereas other people avoid relationships entirely? What is that human difference that makes people go either of those ways? So let's start with, I guess, some basics, not so much a definition, but some parameters around what makes somebody a serial monogamist. There is no definition. I personally think you could label yourself or somebody you know as a serial monogamist. as a serial monogamist when they consistently leave less than three months between significant
那没关系。但问题是，当你这样做时，你失去了什么（如果有的话）？为什么有些人觉得几乎无法单身，而另一些人则完全避免恋爱？是什么样的人类差异导致人们走向这两个极端？所以让我们从一些基础知识开始，与其说是定义，不如说是关于什么使某人成为连续一夫一妻制者的参数。没有定义。我个人认为你可以给自己或你认识的人贴上连续一夫一妻制者的标签。当他们持续在重要的
relationships. Or they consistently leave less than three months between leaving a relationship and actively seeking out another committed relationship. This is not just a one-off. It's not just a long time coming after a breakup. And it's not just rebound relationships after. This is sort out commitment. A rebound relationship, you know, a rebound relationship is usually just a single event. And I think it's usually just about distraction, right? It's partly about soothing. It's partly about proving you're desirable. It's partly about feeling like you need to do the things that single people do after being in a relationship for a while. Sometimes it's just about a new connection. But you kind of know with rebound relationships, they're not going to last. Relationship hopping, though, is seeking
关系之间留出不到三个月的时间时，就是连续一夫一妻制者。或者他们持续在结束一段关系和积极寻求另一段承诺关系之间留出不到三个月的时间。这不仅仅是一次性的。这不仅仅是分手后很久才开始。这也不是分手后的反弹关系。这是寻求承诺。反弹关系，你知道，反弹关系通常只是一个单一事件。我认为它通常只是关于分心，对吧？它部分是关于安慰。它部分是关于证明你是有吸引力的。它部分是关于感觉你需要做单身人士在一段关系中待了一段时间后会做的事情。有时它只是关于一种新的联系。但你对反弹关系有一种了解，它们不会持久。然而，频繁更换伴侣是在寻求
relationships that will be something meaningful for you. And it's this state, emotional state, where being single is like completely intolerable. And you really do require a relationship for emotional stability, a sense of emotional and self-centeredness, not self-centeredness in like the egotistical way, but like self-stability in a way. And you don't know who you are or what to do without it. Again, this isn't some moral flaw or something that you should be ashamed of,
对你有意义的关系。这是一种状态，一种情感状态，在这种状态下，单身是完全无法忍受的。你确实需要一段关系来获得情感稳定，一种情感和自我中心感，不是那种自私意义上的自我中心，而是某种自我稳定。没有它，你不知道你是谁或该做什么。再说一次，这不是什么道德缺陷或你应该感到羞耻的事情，
but you should be aware of it because maybe it is causing you to make rash dating or relationship decisions you otherwise wouldn't. And I honestly think that most of the time, at its minimum, at its lowest, it is causing you to miss out on the deep, deep self-discovery that you get from being alone for a while and the privilege that you get from being single, especially during your 20s. So a big question you may be asking is, again, why am I like this? Why are some people like this? This is where a title, theory comes in, but not as you know it, without giving you like the whole rundown of like all the different attachment styles, because I feel like that's been done to death. Let me just say this.
但你应该意识到这一点，因为也许它导致你做出了本不会做的草率的约会或关系决定。我真心认为，大多数时候，至少在最低限度上，它导致你错过了因为独处一段时间而获得的深刻的自我发现，以及你作为单身人士所获得的特权，尤其是在你20多岁的时候。所以你可能问的一个大问题是，再次，为什么我会这样？为什么有些人会这样？这就是依恋理论发挥作用的地方，但不是你所知道的那样，因为我不想给你列出所有不同依恋风格的全部细节，因为我觉得那已经被讲烂了。让我只说这一点。
Attachment is essentially just your unique blueprint for how you respond to closeness, how you respond to love, how you respond to uncertainty, and how you respond to emotional threats inside and outside of relationships. People with anxious attachment styles are often more likely to be serial monogamous. We know that's probably because they struggle, they struggle with the fear of abandonment, they struggle with the idea that somebody could leave them. So having a label is really comforting. But another influential idea coming from these researchers in the 80s, their names were Cassidy and Coback, basically what they thought was that anxious attached people, they often use hyper-activating strategies to sell soothe, whereas avoidant people use
依恋本质上只是你对亲密关系如何反应、对爱如何反应、对不确定性如何反应以及对关系内外的情感威胁如何反应的独特蓝图。具有焦虑型依恋风格的人通常更有可能成为连续一夫一妻制者。我们知道这可能是因为他们挣扎，他们挣扎于被抛弃的恐惧，他们挣扎于某人可能会离开他们的想法。所以有一个标签真的很令人安慰。但另一个来自80年代研究人员的有影响力的想法，他们的名字是卡西迪和科巴克，他们基本上认为焦虑型依恋的人，他们经常使用过度激活策略来自我安慰，而回避型的人使用
underactivating strategies to self-soof. So essentially, people who are anxious make themselves feel better by turning up the volume and turning up the intensity of a relationship. Reassurance seeking, forcing urgency, forcing proximity, putting more focus on the relationship as a solution to their discomfort, whereas people who are avoidant want to turn all of that down. Seeking proximity, seeking deep intimacy, sometimes with whoever comes through the door first, it is a self-regulating strategy because when we feel dangerous or we feel uncertain about the future, when we feel uncertain about whether we'll find love again, whether we'll be lonely, whether we'll be, whether we'll find peace, it's very easy to put off thinking those things.
低激活策略来自我安慰。所以本质上，焦虑的人通过调高音量和调高关系的强度来让自己感觉更好。寻求保证，强迫紧迫感，强迫亲近，将更多注意力放在关系上作为解决不适的方案，而回避型的人想要调低所有这些。寻求亲近，寻求深度亲密，有时是与任何先出现的人，这是一种自我调节策略，因为当我们感到危险或对未来感到不确定时，当我们感到不确定是否会再次找到爱，是否会孤独，是否会，是否会找到平静时，推迟思考这些事情非常容易。
if you have somebody in your life, you can say, oh, look at this. I've got this person, this person who cares about me. I must be doing something right. That is why some people feel safest when they have a partner, because it feels like something in their life is going right. It feels like they're doing something that society approves of. It feels like, and it represents to them that they have a place to go home to. They have somebody who cares about them and they have been chosen. So there's this whole mix of things bubbling up, anxiety, self-esteem, self-worth, nervous system regulation, attachment. The irony of relationship hopping, though, is that I think, ironically, we think people who are in
如果你的生活中有人，你可以说，哦，看这个。我有这个人，这个关心我的人。我一定做对了什么。这就是为什么有些人有伴侣时感到最安全，因为这感觉像是他们生活中的某件事进展顺利。这感觉像是他们在做社会认可的事情。这感觉像是，并且向他们表明他们有一个可以回家的归宿。他们有一个关心他们的人，他们被选中了。所以这里有一整套东西在冒泡，焦虑、自尊、自我价值、神经系统调节、依恋。然而，频繁更换伴侣的讽刺之处在于，我认为，讽刺的是，我们认为处于
relationships must be secure and those who are out of them must be, have something wrong with their attachment style. But people who are always in relationships are sometimes the most anxious and disorganized, people internally. Being partnered doesn't automatically equal emotional safety or emotional maturity. It can sometimes just be that we have this coping strategy of seeking emotional closeness with others that means, you know, from the outside, it always seems like everything's going well. It always seems like we've got somebody who cares about us and loves us. And, you know, we must be, we must be the shit. We must be pretty great. But the thing is, is that those relationships,
关系中的人一定是安全的，而那些处于关系之外的人一定在依恋风格上有什么问题。但总是处于关系中的人有时在内心深处是最焦虑和混乱的。拥有伴侣并不自动等同于情感安全或情感成熟。有时这可能只是我们有一种寻求与他人情感亲近的应对策略，这意味着，你知道，从外面看，一切似乎总是进展顺利。似乎我们总是有一个关心我们并爱我们的人。而且，你知道，我们一定是，我们一定是太棒了。但问题是，那些关系，
and I'm not going to speak for your experiences, just from what I've seen, those relationships are often quite shallow. Because real vulnerability and real connection, like, we know this, you know this. It takes time. And it takes difficult things to bond, to bond people together. It's awkward. Real vulnerability is actually really awkward because it involves risk.
我不会代表你的经历发言，只是根据我所看到的，那些关系通常相当肤浅。因为真正的脆弱和真正的联系，就像，我们知道这一点，你知道这一点。这需要时间。而且需要困难的事情来将人们联系在一起。这很尴尬。真正的脆弱实际上非常尴尬，因为它涉及风险。
It involves the risk of reaching out to somebody and then rejecting you. It involves the risk. risk of being chosen and being safe and being loved and then maybe somebody turning around and not feeling those same things towards you. And, you know, just kind of knowing that, knowing that's a possibility and still trusting them, especially in those early stages, especially when you're first getting to know somebody. Now, if you are somebody who is very anxious and has a deep rooted fear of rejection or abandonment, those early days, those early stages of risk and vulnerability and uncertainty, that can be unbearable. It can be unbearable to like your self-esteem
它涉及向某人伸出援手然后被拒绝的风险。它涉及被选中、安全和被爱，然后也许某人转身并没有对你有同样感觉的风险。而且，你知道，只是知道这一点，知道这是一种可能性，仍然信任他们，尤其是在那些早期阶段，尤其是在你刚开始了解某人的时候。现在，如果你是一个非常焦虑并且有根深蒂固的被拒绝或被抛弃恐惧的人，那些早期日子，那些风险、脆弱和不确定性的早期阶段，那可能是无法忍受的。这对你的自尊
and to your sense of emotional safety. So instead, you chase that artificial closeness. You chase the closeness that is created by structure and created by proximity and created by a label and created by fast commitment and fast enmeshment and fast emotional intimacy, rather than just sometimes letting things happen naturally. And it's not manipulative. This isn't a character flaw. It's self-protection. It's the logic of thinking.
和你的情感安全感来说可能是无法忍受的。所以相反，你追求那种人为的亲近。你追求那种由结构创造的、由亲近创造的、由标签创造的、由快速承诺和快速纠缠以及快速情感亲密创造的亲近，而不是有时让事情自然发生。这并不是操纵。这不是性格缺陷。这是自我保护。这是那种认为的逻辑。
If I make this official really quickly, if I lock this person down fast, I'll be safe. If, you know, who cares if I just met this person three weeks ago, a week ago, if they're my partner and they have that label, then they can't leave me. That's one more barrier to them walking out of me like the last person did or this relationship crumbling like the last one did. Really, I think sometimes relationship hopping is really just a way of avoiding the grief associated with past hurt. You know, think about what happens after a breakup. You're going to feel something. You have to feel something. Pain, betrayal, longing, anger. And there's,
如果我很快让这段关系正式化，如果我很快锁定这个人，我就会安全。如果，你知道，谁在乎我是否三周前、一周前才认识这个人，如果他们是我的伴侣，他们有那个标签，那么他们就不能离开我。这是他们像上一个人那样离开我，或者这段关系像上一段那样崩溃的又一道障碍。真的，我认为有时频繁更换伴侣真的只是逃避与过去伤害相关的悲伤的一种方式。你知道，想想分手后会发生什么。你会感觉到什么。你必须感觉到什么。痛苦、背叛、渴望、愤怒。而且有，
often this quiet period that really demands we sit with ourselves and let ourselves be confronted with really big emotional questions that kind of suck to answer, but questions like, who am I outside of this relationship? What do I do with my evenings now? Why didn't this work out? What happens if I don't find somebody better? What happens if I don't find somebody period? And for, you know, a period of time, we don't know the answer to those questions. We don't know who we are outside of a relationship. We don't know for certain if we're going to be okay. If we're going to find somebody we like as much as that last person. So sometimes it's a lot easier to turn all of that inward focus outwards because it doesn't require you to answer any of those questions. Being in a
通常这段安静的时期确实要求我们与自己坐在一起，让我们面对一些非常大的情感问题，这些问题回答起来很糟糕，但像这样的问题，在这个关系之外我是谁？我现在晚上做什么？为什么这段关系没有成功？如果我找不到更好的人怎么办？如果我根本找不到人怎么办？而且在一段时间内，我们不知道这些问题的答案。我们不知道在关系之外我们是谁。我们不知道如果我们要好起来是否确定。如果我们是否会找到一个像上一个人那样让我们喜欢的人。所以有时把所有这些内在的焦点转向外部要容易得多，因为它不需要你回答任何这些问题。处于
relationship answers those questions for you. Who am I outside of this relationship? Doesn't matter. I've got this new relationship. What do I do with my evenings now? Doesn't matter. I've got this person. I spend it with them. You know, why didn't it work out? well, this relationship is working out. Will I ever find somebody better? Well, look, I just did. Relationships give you a role. They give you something to, they give you answers, they give you something to pour your energy into, they give you a guaranteed plan, a guaranteed sense of self-worth, and a sense that you've been picked. And I get it. It's absolutely terrifying when you have that designated relationship free time, especially if it's the first time in your life, you've
关系中会为你回答这些问题。在这个关系之外我是谁？没关系。我有这段新关系。我现在晚上做什么？没关系。我有这个人。我和他们一起度过。你知道，为什么它没有成功？好吧，这段关系正在成功。我会找到更好的人吗？好吧，看，我刚刚找到了。关系给你一个角色。它们给你一些东西，它们给你答案，它们给你一些东西来倾注你的精力，它们给你一个保证的计划，一个保证的自我价值感，以及一种你被选中的感觉。我明白。当你拥有那种指定的无关系时间时，这绝对是可怕的，尤其是如果这是你一生中第一次，你
truly been single. You're not used to spending this time focusing on you and what you actually want in life. And so a relationship becomes a way of filling those holes or those gaps in your self-confidence and your self-esteem. There's this whole theory about this from the 90s, which basically says, I think it's called sociometer theory, sociomina, sociometer theory. There we go. Sorry, tripped over my words there. But it essentially says that when somebody really ties their sense of self-worth to external things, the loss of such external things can feel much more painful than if you are somebody who ties your worth to internal things. And the only way you can tie your worth to internal things is if you do the work. And as if you take those
真正单身。你不习惯花这段时间专注于你自己以及你在生活中真正想要的东西。所以一段关系成为填补你自信和自尊中那些空洞或缺口的一种方式。关于这一点，90年代有一个完整的理论，基本上说，我想它叫社会计量理论，社会计量，社会计量理论。好了。抱歉，我刚才说错了。但它本质上说，当某人真正将他们的自我价值感与外部事物联系起来时，失去这些外部事物会比你是一个将价值与内在事物联系起来的人感觉痛苦得多。而你将价值与内在事物联系起来的唯一方法就是如果你做了这些工作。并且如果你利用那些
moments of being single or not even being single, being alone, being scared, being unsure, and you show yourself you are capable of handling it yourself. Again, if your self-esteem is deeply tied to being accepted and chosen, and you don't have that additional part of you that says, it's okay, we'll be fine if we're not chosen because we'll have ourselves. A breakup is like an emotional emergency. It is like an emotional collapse. it's like catastrophe.
单身甚至不是单身、独处、害怕、不确定的时刻，并向自己证明你有能力自己处理它。再说一次，如果你的自尊与被接受和被选中深深联系在一起，而你没有那部分说，没关系，如果我们没有被选中我们也会很好，因为我们会拥有我们自己，那么分手就像一场情感紧急情况。这就像一场情感崩溃。这就像灾难。
And so sometimes your brain is going to look for the easiest solution to that. And what is the easiest band-aid solution fix? Find somebody else. Find somebody else who's going to quickly fill that whole ride up, who's going to make you feel validated again, make you feel safe again, make you feel chosen again. That is why we find ourselves in this pattern. There's something else going on here, though.
所以有时你的大脑会寻找最简单的解决方案。什么是最简单的创可贴解决方案？找另一个人。找另一个人，他会很快填补那个空洞，他会让你再次感到被认可，让你再次感到安全，让你再次感到被选中。这就是为什么我们发现自己处于这种模式中。这里还有别的事情发生，
Something I would say is a little bit more positive. And it comes down to, the excitement and novelty we love when we fall in love with people that we get addicted to when we meet new people. So we're going to dive into that explanation and so much more after this short break. Two percent. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical
我想说的是更积极一点的事情。它归结为，当我们爱上我们沉迷的人时，当我们遇到新的人时，我们所爱的那种兴奋和新奇感。所以我们将在短暂休息后深入探讨那个解释以及更多内容。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，关于心理韧性、健身和建立复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家交谈，更多地去审视那些不切实际的
and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people.
和过于复杂的伪科学，这些伪科学主导了健康产业。我们真的相信种子油本质上是炎症性的。我们错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些磨难，你就会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《2%》。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。
I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do a Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at a podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill,
我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什和小金有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at it》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会挑选一年，拆解当时发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何度过那一年的。包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的对话，
waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
大谈80年代的快克。明确地说，84年对我来说很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我愿意在某天谈论快克，但只是让你们知道。我的意思是，在这一点上，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集。所以我开始看到有一条主线。我们现在桌面上还有艾滋病。谢谢你完成那句话。是的。我不认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。
Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase
真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Look Back at it》。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》，我是你们的主持人，也是你们最喜欢的治疗师，基尔·盖恩斯。为了响应心理健康意识月，我带来了我自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，并与许多不可思议的嘉宾进行了对话。我在说。特里普·方丹，瑞安·克拉克。有时当我们追求某样东西时，我们太沉迷于追逐
that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you here on earth. Or are you a good person because you're afraid?
以至于我们没有意识到我们已经拥有了那个东西。而我们还在追逐它。我们不知道什么时候已经做得足够了。因为人们在看记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在你活在地球上时做一个好人很重要。还是你做一个好人是因为你害怕？
Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's just. different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keir Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This
因为那是两种不同的意图，兄弟。绝对是。而且那只是。不同程度的信任。我希望你真的做一个好人。加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》中，我们进行关于治愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标的真实对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用程序。搜索《Learn the Hardway》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会揭示了她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这
began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfectant. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
开始了长达数年的法庭斗争以证明真相。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吧？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一支互联网侦探大军来破案。我希望人们能够看到他们的税款被用于什么。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们揭露了一个令人不安的模式。还有两个男人也经历过同样的事情。
Greg Alesspian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona.
格雷格·阿莱斯皮安，迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。我的大脑被震撼了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trap》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着这一季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控欺诈。在亚利桑那州正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。
Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with. with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And Rule 2, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends...
在Iheart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。任何男人都应该遵守两条黄金法则。规则一，永远不要招惹。乡村女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，你就会得到愚蠢的奖品。规则二，也永远不要招惹她的朋友。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在《The Girlfriends》这一新季中……
Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast.
天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都与同一个多产的骗子约会过。我觉得我被卡车撞了。我想，这怎么可能发生在我身上？警察似乎并不关心。所以她们决定采取行动。我说，哦，见鬼不。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他会得到他应得的。收听《The Girlfriends》。相信我，宝贝。在Iheart电台应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听。
Okay, so far we've talked about relationship hopping as something that is driven by fear, insecurity, avoidance, that kind of stuff. There is another version of the story that is completely different. Sometimes people relationship hop because, for falling in love feels incredible, and that is the state that they want to be in forever. Sometimes people are serial monogamous because they are chasing that very specific experience, the experience, the temporary and yet deeply addictive experience of falling in love. Let's be real, like the early stages of any relationship is the best. Like, it's the best. It's one of the best feelings in the world.
好的，到目前为止，我们已经讨论了频繁更换伴侣是出于恐惧、不安全感、回避等因素。这个故事还有另一个完全不同的版本。有时人们频繁更换伴侣是因为，坠入爱河的感觉令人难以置信，而这就是他们想要永远保持的状态。有时人们是连续一夫一妻制者，因为他们在追求那种非常具体的体验，那种坠入爱河的、暂时的却又让人深深上瘾的体验。让我们面对现实吧，任何关系的早期阶段都是最好的。就像，它是最好的。这是世界上最好的感觉之一。
When you are like on date three or four, maybe five with like somebody you're really, really into and it's all anticipation and obsession and everything is new and there's like this little secret like this relationship just feels like this little private thing between you and the other person you know your whole world becomes like what am I going to see this person next I wonder what they're thinking about me like feeling giddy feeling excited for the future and the passion and that high is biological it's meant to drive us to connect with people and to have those early moments of deep bonding that will, you know, kind of push us towards long-term commitment. It's meant to give us, like, it's no mistake and it's no accident that
当你和某个你非常非常喜欢的人在第三或第四次，也许第五次约会时，一切都是期待和痴迷，一切都是新的，而且有一种小秘密，就像这段关系感觉像是你和对方之间的小私事，你知道你的整个世界变成了，我什么时候会再见到这个人，我想知道他们在想我吗，就像感到头晕目眩，对未来感到兴奋，激情，那种高潮是生物性的，它旨在驱动我们与人建立联系，并拥有那些深度结合的早期时刻，这些时刻会，你知道，某种程度上推动我们走向长期承诺。它旨在给我们，就像，这不是错误，也不是意外，
the early days of a relationship create this bonding high. There was a study in 2005 done on this from researchers in New Jersey who basically scanned the brains of 17 participants who were all loved up and then asked them to look at a photograph of the person. person they were really in love with or just recently had started really dating or falling for and then to look at a person like a photo of just somebody random and what they found was that there was these whole segments of their brain that just showed in like crazy activity levels. It was like the right ventral area and I think like the right um coordinate nucleus like this basically the area is associated with reward and motivation not like that's where love is in
关系的早期日子创造了这种结合的高潮。2005年，新泽西州的研究人员对此进行了一项研究，他们基本上扫描了17名处于恋爱状态的参与者的脑部，然后要求他们看一张他们真正爱的人，或者最近刚开始真正约会或爱上的人的照片，然后看一张随机人的照片，他们发现他们大脑中有整段区域显示出疯狂的活动水平。就像右腹侧区域，我想还有右尾状核，基本上这些区域与奖励和动机有关，不是说爱就在你的大脑里。它在奖励和那些奖励与动机区域。本质上，你的大脑感受到了如此多的积极事物，并且像是在说，让我们进一步追求它，并且确实在激活你大脑中的那些系统。当你坠入爱河时，他们会想要你这样做。你也被加压素、催产素淹没了，所有这些在化学上感觉很棒的东西。让你感觉不可思议。多巴胺也一样。多巴胺在这个过程中起着巨大的作用，它在激励你想要更多地见到他们，在他们的存在中感觉良好，感觉像是不确定性和不可预测性的高潮，这在关系的开始确实非常引人入胜。就像，这会成功吗？这个人会是
your brain. It's in reward and it's in those reward and motivational areas. Essentially, your brain is feeling so many positive things and is like, let's chase that further and is really activating those systems in your brain. They're going to want you to do that as you fall in love. You're also being flooded with vasopressin, oxytocin, all these things that chemically feel great. Make you feel incredible. Dopamine as well. Dopamine plays a huge role in this process and it plays a huge role in motivating you to want to see them more, to feel good in their presence, to feel like the highs of uncertainty and unpredictability that is honestly so enthralling about the start of a relationship. Like, is this going to work out? Is this person going to be
那个人吗，你的整个系统，浪漫爱情的整个系统旨在让人上瘾。它旨在激励人。它旨在真正运行在这种高度的奖励水平上。我知道这听起来不浪漫，但它确实很好地解释了连续一夫一妻制。新的爱情之所以如此令人上瘾，是因为它让我们进入了一种强大的情感强度、强迫性思维、高度注意力的状态。如果那种奖励状态成为某人对生活感到兴奋、有目标感、某人第一次或很长一段时间以来感到情感上被激活的主要方式之一，
the one, your whole system, the whole system of romantic love is meant to be addictive. It's meant to be motivational. It's meant to really run on this heightened level of reward. And I know that doesn't sound romantic, but it does explain serial monogamy really well. New love is so addictive because it puts us into this powerful state of emotional intensity, of obsessional thinking, of heightened attention. And if that reward state becomes one of the main ways that someone feels excited about life, purposeful, somebody feels emotionally switched on for the first time or in a long time,
他们一次又一次地追求那种感觉是有道理的，就像赢的感觉，就像喝醉的感觉，就像吸毒的感觉。然而，如果/当关系结束时，崩溃是深刻的。如果他们一直在追求一段又一段的关系，这种崩溃是非常深刻的。而不去感受崩溃、不去感受宿醉的唯一方法就是再次喝醉，再次沉迷于爱情。那么这对我们在生物学上、情感上有什么影响呢，因为你可能在想，
it makes sense that they would chase that feeling again and again and again, like the feeling of winning, like the feeling of getting drunk, like the feeling of getting high. However, if slash when the relationship ends, the crash is profound. It is deeply profound if they have been chasing relationship after relationship. And what is the only way to not feel the crash, to not feel the hangover, is to get drunk again, is to get high on love again. So what does this do to us, biologically, emotionally, because you may be thinking like,
这有什么害处？爱感觉很棒，因为我们注定要在我们的一生中尽可能多地体验它，我并不反对这一点。你知道，这对性格发展很有好处。即使它没有成功，至少我学到了一个教训。就像，我学到了更多关于我自己的东西，然后有一天我在一起的那个人，他们就是那个人。就像，尽可能多地让自己处于爱的道路上有什么害处？老实说，我觉得这很难反驳，但在逻辑和理性上，你实际上
what's the harm in this? Love feels great because we're meant to experience it as much as possible. in our lifetime, which I don't disagree with. You know, it's great for character development. Even if it doesn't work out, at least I learn a lesson. Like, I learn more about myself and then one day the person I'm with, they will be the one. Like, what's the harm in just putting myself on the line in the path of love as much as possible? I think I find that hard to argue with, to be honest, but logically and rationally, you do actually
当你没有给自己时间单身时，确实会失去很多。从一段认真的关系进展到另一段认真的关系，尤其是当涉及高度的绝望、恐惧和痴迷时，会对你的性格发展产生影响，也会对你的情感发展产生影响。我认为害处在于，你永远没有机会弄清楚在上一段关系结束后，作为这个新版本的你是谁。更广泛地说，就像，你永远没有机会弄清楚独自一人时你是谁。所以你将永远，如果你不能适应独处，你将永远受制于一个可能会离开你的人。我指的不仅仅是伴侣。我指的是朋友。我指的是家庭成员。我指的是任何人。
lose a lot when you do not give yourself time to be single. And progressing from serious relationship to serious relationship, especially when there is a high degree of desperation and fear and obsession involved, will do things to your character development and will do things to your emotional development. I think the harm is that you don't ever get the chance to figure out who you are as this new version of you after this previous relationship has ended. And more generally, like, you just never get the chance to figure out who you are alone. And so you will always be, if you can't get comfortable being alone, you will always be at the mercy of somebody who could leave you. And I don't just mean a partner. I mean friends. I mean family members. I mean anyone.
你永远不会发展出那种，我可以处理这个，我知道我自己，我知道我有能力，我可以依靠自己。那是你的脊梁。每个人都需要那个，因为在任何时候，你知道，悲剧发生了，生活发生了。如果你从来没有感到独处很舒服，当不可避免地，也许宇宙，世界强迫你独处时，你会环顾四周，没有任何应对策略，也不知道如何在这里，在那个时刻待在那里。我认为这是那种代价，对我们独立性的代价是
You never develop that sense of like, I can handle this. I know myself. I know I am capable. I can rely on myself. That is your backbone. Everybody needs that because at any point, you know, tragedy happens, life happens. If you never feel comfortable being by yourself, when you inevitably, perhaps the universe, the world forces you to be by yourself, you will look around and have no coping strategies and have no idea how to be here and be there in that moment. I think it's that cost, the cost to our independence that is the good.
最大的，因为那些你独处的生命阶段是你能够积极考虑你自己的原因。你不必考虑任何其他人的需求、任何其他人的偏好或日常习惯，你不必对任何其他人的情绪负责，你只需要对你自己负责。而在这些时期，你才真正能够表达，我想要从我一生中得到什么？我想要从我在这里的时间里得到什么？我真正喜欢做什么？我真实而真实的日常流程是什么样的？也许你回答了那个问题，然后说，
greatest because those stretches of life where you are alone is what allows you to actively consider just you. You don't have to think about anybody else's needs, anybody else's preferences or routines, you're not responsible for anybody else's emotions, you're just responsible for you. And in those periods is where you are really able to articulate, what do I want out of my one shot at life? What do I want out of my time here? What do I really like doing? What does my true and authentic daily flow look like? And maybe you answer that question and go,
我真正想要从我一生中得到的是找到一个很棒的人，然后你就去做了。但如果你不在某个阶段，你知道，停止让自己的频率不断被别人的频率打断，以及那些并不总是停留很长时间的人，你怎么会知道呢？关系，你知道，无论你喜欢与否，它们都会塑造你的日常生活，它们会塑造你的身份，它们甚至会塑造你对未来的想象，它们尤其会塑造你的思想。我总是这样想。你最常想到某人或其他人的两个时间点之一，当你爱上他们时，或者当你爱上他们时
what I really want out of my one true life is to find someone to be amazing and you go about that. But how will you know if you do not at some stage, you know, stop letting your own frequency be constantly interrupted by somebody else's and people who don't always stay for very long. relationships, you know, whether you like it or not, they will shape your daily life, they will shape your identity, they will shape even your future imagination, they will especially shape your thoughts. I always think about this. One of the two times you think about somebody or other people the most when you are falling in love with them or when you are falling out
不再爱他们时，或者当你为他们悲伤时。如果你总是处于这两个状态之一，坠入爱河，分手，坠入爱河，分手，心理空间变得非常拥挤，你留给自己的心理空间变得非常有限。你对自己的身份和需求所拥有的那些想法并不自私。它们对于自我发展绝对至关重要，对于你表达自己想要和需要的能力绝对至关重要。所以如果你发现，因为这并不总是适合每个人，但如果你发现处于一段关系中阻止了你优先考虑这一点，而你不断地处于关系中，时间，当你不处于关系中的时候，
of love with them or when you are grieving them. If you are always in one of those two states, falling in love, breaking up, falling in love, breaking up, the, mental real estate becomes very crowded and the mental real estate you have left for yourself becomes very limited. Those thoughts that you have concerning your own identity and your own needs are not selfish. They are absolutely essential for self-development, absolutely essential for your ability to articulate your wants and needs. And so if you find, because it's not always going to be for everybody, but if you find being in a relationship stops you from being able to prioritize that, and you are constantly in relationships, the time, when the time comes that you are not in a relationship,
与他们相爱或为他们悲伤。如果你总是处于这两种状态之一，坠入爱河、分手、再坠入爱河、再分手，那么你的心理空间就会变得非常拥挤，留给自己的心理空间就会变得非常有限。你关于自我认同和自身需求的那些想法并不是自私的。它们对于自我发展绝对是必不可少的，对于你表达自己愿望和需求的能力也绝对是必不可少的。所以，如果你发现——因为这并不总是适用于每个人——但如果你发现处于一段关系中让你无法优先考虑这些，而你又总是处于恋爱关系中，那么当你不处于恋爱关系中的时候，
when the time comes when you have to really look in the mirror and be like, wait, what do I want? You may find it really hard to answer that question. Another thing that can happen over time is that you don't always get the chance to actually consolidate relational learning. So maybe again, you answer that question, what do I want out of my life and it's to be in love? Being in a relationship constantly probably won't actually help you in that either. most people understand relationships through experiences, right? You date, you make mistakes, you notice what you do and don't like, what you avoid, what you repeat.
当那一刻来临，你必须真正审视镜子里的自己，问自己：等等，我到底想要什么？你可能会发现回答这个问题非常困难。随着时间的推移，另一件可能发生的事情是，你并不总是有机会真正巩固在人际关系中学到的东西。所以，也许你再次回答了那个问题——我的人生想要什么？答案是想要坠入爱河。但不断地处于恋爱关系中，可能并不能真正帮助你实现这一点。大多数人通过经历来理解人际关系，对吧？你约会，你犯错，你注意到你喜欢什么、不喜欢什么，你回避什么，你重复什么。
Maybe you break up, maybe you don't, but you have to learn something. If you do break up, you have to, you get something from that. And the research shows that learning in this case or learning of any kind tends to crystallize and become more substantial and impactful when there is a pause between the next lesson. when you can reflect without immediately being swept up in the emotional demands or cognitive demands of something new. I think one of the most valuable things you can do in the aftermath of a relationship is like the painful work of self-reflection. And I think that is a way of honoring the relationship, even if it didn't work out. I think it also really helps you close the story of the
也许你会分手，也许不会，但你必须学到些什么。如果你分手了，你必须从中获得一些东西。研究表明，在这种情况下或任何形式的学习，当下一课之间有停顿的时候，学习往往会结晶，变得更加扎实和有影响力。当你可以在不立即被新事物的各种情感或认知需求所淹没的情况下进行反思时。我认为在一段关系结束后，你能做的最有价值的事情之一就是进行痛苦的自我反思。我认为这是一种尊重这段关系的方式，即使它没有成功。我也认为这真的能帮助你结束这段关系的故事，
relationship by acknowledging like, in doing this work and acknowledging like, yes, this really hurt. I really didn't want it to end this way. I wish it had ended differently, but it didn't. And this is why. Sometimes you don't get a future, you get a lesson. And that can be just as valuable if you take time to absorb it. Without the pause, and I'm sorry, I'm really laboring on this point, but without the pause, you still move forward,
通过承认这一点，在做这项工作时承认：是的，这真的很痛。我真的不希望它以这种方式结束。我希望它能有不同的结局，但事实并非如此。这就是原因。有时你得不到未来，你得到的是一个教训。如果你花时间去吸收它，这同样有价值。如果没有停顿——抱歉，我一直在强调这一点——但如果没有停顿，你虽然继续前行，
but you don't always integrate any of that learning into your next relationship. And that is where unhealthy patterns that cause marital breakdowns, divorce, deep betrayal, that's where they come from. The repetition of unhealthy patterns that are never dealt with. So when do we know it's time to break the pattern? When can we look in the mirror and be like, oh, I think I need a break from dating. I think this may be me. I would say when you realize that dating stops being about connection and fun and starts
但你并不总是能将这些经验整合到下一段关系中。而这正是导致婚姻破裂、离婚、深度背叛等不健康模式的根源。那些从未被处理过的不健康模式的重复。那么，我们什么时候才知道是时候打破这种模式了呢？什么时候我们可以看着镜子说：哦，我想我需要休息一下，停止约会。我想这可能是我自己的问题。我会说，当你意识到约会不再是关于连接和乐趣，而开始
being about urgency and self-confidence, then you need to take a step back. When you notice that you are really just going on dates with anyone, you are letting dating take over your life. When your type always ends up leading to the same ending, it's time to take a break. I think the biggest indicator though is when you don't even know what you want anymore. You're just doing it. You're just dating without intention. You feel a little bit lost with it. You feel equally lost without it. You feel equally lost without it. There's like this gap that needs to be filled and you just feel like I cannot sit still until I have somebody. I think that is the biggest sign. In those moments, that is when you need to do a dating detox. I've spoken about this so often on the podcast
变成关于紧迫感和自我证明时，你就需要退后一步了。当你注意到你真的只是在和任何人约会，你让约会占据了你的生活。当你的“类型”总是导致同样的结局时，是时候休息一下了。但我认为最大的指标是当你甚至不知道自己想要什么的时候。你只是在做这件事。你只是在没有意图地约会。你对此感到有点迷茫。没有它你也感到同样迷茫。没有它你也感到同样迷茫。就像有一个需要填补的空白，你只是觉得如果不找个人，我就无法静下心来。我认为这是最大的信号。在那些时刻，就是你需要进行“约会排毒”的时候。我在播客上经常提到这一点，
before. I'm so sorry if you are like, God, can she be quiet about this? But it's because it is so helpful. Literally saying to yourself, same way you do an hour. alcohol detox, the same way you may do a detox to quit smoking. If you literally just give yourself six months and say, dating is not on the table in the slightest during this period, and I'll come back to it later, but I really, I don't have to think about it for this period of time. You will come back with such a better understanding of what you want. Like, I cannot speak highly enough of taking some clear designated time away from dating
之前提到过。如果你觉得“天哪，她能不能别再提这个了”，我真的很抱歉。但这是因为它真的很有帮助。就像你进行酒精排毒，或者为了戒烟而进行排毒一样，如果你真的给自己六个月的时间，说这段期间完全不考虑约会，以后再回来处理，但在这段时间里我真的不需要去想它。当你回来时，你会对自己想要什么有更好的理解。我极力推荐抽出一段明确的、专门的时间远离约会，
to really address, like, if love, love. is something that I obviously need, we all need it. If love and monogamy in the future is something I want, what will that look like for me? And how will I know when I have it? And how will I know when my needs are not being fulfilled? I just think that a dating detox and six months, I don't know, it's just the best. It resets like your emotional biome. Like it returns you to the stable, secure point. You know how I always think about it? It's like your frequency is not being constantly interrupted. So you are able to very clearly signal to others and signal to yourself what you want. And if you are finding that you relate to any of this, I think this is the easiest way to go about it.
去真正解决问题，比如：如果爱，爱是我显然需要的，我们都需要它。如果未来我想要爱和一夫一妻制，那对我来说会是什么样子？我怎么知道我什么时候拥有了它？我怎么知道我的需求何时没有得到满足？我只是认为“约会排毒”六个月，我不知道，这简直太棒了。它重置了你的情感生物群落。它让你回到稳定、安全的点。你知道我总是怎么想的吗？就像你的频率没有被不断地打断。所以你能够非常清晰地向他人以及向自己发出你想要的信号。如果你发现自己与这些产生共鸣，我认为这是最简单的做法。
Take relationships off the table, deal with the discomfort and it will be uncomfortable. But know that like this is an investment in your future self, in yourself right now. And in any relationship you find yourself in in the future. because you're going to come into it with so much more clarity and a much clear idea of what you want and how you go about making relationships work. I think it doesn't mean breaking off of, like, you don't have to stop dating forever. And you're not doing this as punishment, right? You're not punishing yourself. I should have said that very clearly up front. This is like the freedom to just let your mind relax without constantly having this like hypervigilance towards, you know, romantic interest
把人际关系先搁置一边，去面对不适感，这确实会让人不舒服。但要知道，这是对你未来的自己、对现在的自己以及对你未来可能进入的任何关系的投资。因为你会带着更多的清晰度，以及对你想要什么和如何经营人际关系有更明确的想法进入下一段关系。我认为这并不意味着要彻底断绝，你不必永远停止约会。你这样做也不是为了惩罚自己，对吧？你不是在惩罚自己。我应该在开头就说清楚。这就像是一种自由，让你的思想放松，而不必总是对浪漫兴趣保持这种过度警惕，
without constantly having this like part of your brain that is switched on to other people and switched on to like, who am I going to date next? It's not forever. It's just for a moment. And I think it can be incredibly powerful for literally anybody. So I hope you enjoyed this episode. I hope you learned something about relationship hopping and serial monogamy. I'm sorry I sound so sick in this episode. I feel like I've been saying that every single episode recently. So I really appreciate your patience with whatever this nasal congestion thing is ever since I moved to London. Make sure that you are following us on Instagram, that psychology podcast, on Substack. If you want to read some article versions to do with the psychology of your 20s straight into your inbox. Or if you
不必让大脑中那部分总是处于开启状态，去关注其他人，去关注“我接下来要和谁约会”。这不是永远的。只是暂时的。我认为这对任何人来说都可能非常有力量。所以我希望你喜欢这一集。我希望你学到了一些关于“关系跳跃”和“连续一夫一妻制”的知识。很抱歉我在这一集中听起来病得很重。我觉得最近每一集我都在说这个。所以我真的很感谢你们对我自从搬到伦敦后出现的这种鼻塞问题的耐心。确保你在Instagram上关注我们，关注那个心理学播客，关注Substack。如果你想阅读与你20多岁心理学相关的文章版本，直接发送到你的收件箱。或者如果你
want to hear our studies of the week to finish the year so much smarter, so much more informed. You can also now watch the podcast on Netflix. I feel like I've been talking about this for ages, but if you are in Canada, oh, actually I should say, Canada, the US, UK, Australia, Southeast Asia. It's available everywhere. Well, not everywhere, but everywhere in those places, as of right now. So go and watch it. Make sure to tag us in your stories or if you post anything about it. I would love to see it. I appreciate you making it to the end. Leave a little heart emoji if you, down below, if you're listening on Spotify, and if you are still here, thank you for listening. Thank you, as always, to our researcher Libby Colbert for her contributions to this episode. And until next time,
想听听我们本周的研究，以便在年底时变得更聪明、更见多识广。你现在也可以在Netflix上观看这个播客。我觉得我已经谈论这个很久了，但如果你在加拿大，哦，其实我应该说，加拿大、美国、英国、澳大利亚、东南亚。它在各地都有提供。好吧，不是各地，但在那些地方目前都有。所以去看看吧。如果你发布了关于它的任何内容，请务必在你的故事中标记我们。我很乐意看到它。感谢你坚持听到最后。如果你在Spotify上收听，请在下方留下一个小爱心表情，如果你还在听，谢谢你的收听。一如既往地感谢我们的研究员Libby Colbert对本集的贡献。直到下一次，
be safe, be kind, especially if you relate to this episode. Be very gentle with yourself. We will talk very, very soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building
保持安全，保持善良，特别是如果你与这一集产生共鸣的话。对自己温柔一点。我们很快就会再聊。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是Michael Easter。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了心理韧性、健身和建立
resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%.
在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立韧性的科学。让自己经历一些磨难，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。
That's TWO%. On the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at a podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J.
那是《2%》。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听。关于播客的回顾。从1979年开始，那对我来说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我来说也很重要。我是Sam J.
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是Alex English。每一集，我们都会挑选一年，拆解发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何度过那一年的。和我们的朋友、喜剧演员同行以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如Mark Lamont Hill谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我不认为还有比这更重要的年份了，对黑人来说。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? listening to learn the hard way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with.
在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Look Back At It》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？正在收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师和主持人Kear Games。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行一些在其他任何地方都不太安全的诚实对话，但你是在与一位知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着盔甲？它向世界发出信号：你不是好惹的。
And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2023年，《单身汉》明星Clayton Eckerd被指控生下双胞胎。但怀孕似乎是一个骗局。Owens女士，你两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吧？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一支互联网侦探大军来揭开一个令人不安的模式。还有两个男人也经历过同样的事情。
Greg, a lesbian. Michael Margini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is love trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens. finally faces consequences.
Greg，一个女同性恋者。Michael Margini。我的大脑被震撼了。我是Stephanie Young。这是《Love Trapped》。Laura，Scottsdale警察局。随着季节的继续，Laura Owens终于面临后果。
Listen to a love-trapped podcast on the IHeart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。当一群女性发现她们都与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们采取了行动。我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他不会逃脱惩罚的。他会得到他应得的。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。
Listen to the girlfriend. Trust me, babe, on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast, guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《The Girlfriend: Trust Me, Babe》。这是一个iHeart播客，保证是人类制作的。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。